a second Game of Thrones Season 7
trailer is out and there is a heap of
cool stuff in here so let's have a look
we get some great shots of Dragonstone
the old island stronghold of the
Targaryen swear Daenerys has finally
arrived
dragon stone looks way crazier in the
books with huge stone dragons and
hundreds of gargoyles it's also a
volcanic island with caves full of
obsidian or a dragon glass one of the
only materials known that can kill White
Walkers so dragon stones obsidian should
be really important this season dragon
stone was held by the Targaryen for
centuries until Robert Baratheon took
over and gave the island to his brother
Stannis this is Stannis is bana here but
now Stannis is dead and Danny's arrived
it's time to redecorate then he takes
down the banner symbolically returning
the castle to her family she again looks
over the painted table map of Westeros
representing her plans to conquer the
kingdoms we also see Danny's dragon
drogon whose huge now look how tiny Dany
is perched on his back dragons looking a
lot like balerion the black dread the
famous dragon of Aegon the conquerer who
first took Westeros 300 years ago
Dany is very much walking in her
ancestors footsteps to take Westeros
though Danny's got a sale from
Dragonstone to the mainland which should
be easy but we see she's attacked at sea
by euron greyjoy a neuron doesn't play
fair he uses some explosive fiery weapon
against Danny's fleet which Yara and
Theon aren't too keen on Yara leaps into
battle because she's Yara [ __ ] Greyjoy
while Theon stands and looks upset
because he's Theon [ __ ] gradually
Theon at least does survive we see him
collapsing on a beach like in Planet of
the Apes but it looks like this battle
goes well for you Ron because we then
see him sailing into King's Landing
this red smudge on the Greyjoy Kraken on
his sails might represent Euron's
heraldry in the books a red eye with a
crown and crows Huron might have come to
visit Queen Cersei maybe he's being
welcomed into the city in this shot
though maybe someone else it's hard to
say either way the relationship between
Euron and so
see could be a really big deal this
season the Circe for her part is
standing in what might be the basement
of the red cape where they keep the old
tug Aryan dragon skulls from years ago
maybe Cersei has finally realized that
Daenerys and her dragons are a threat
and is trying to work out how to slay
dragons for the record dragons in Game
of Thrones have been killed with
scorpion bolts arrows even by angry
peasants when they're trapped indoors so
Danny's dragons can definitely be killed
and there's also the possibility they
might be magically mind-controlled by
someone like brand or Bloodraven or
Euron in the books or even by the night
king so Danny's dragons are powerful but
[ __ ] can and probably will happen to
them for now though Danny and her
dragons are kicking us we see a huge
battle with Danny on dragon with
Dothraki attacking some Lannister
soldiers including Jaime and Bronn
things get hot and heavy what will the
Dragon Fire which is reminiscent of a
huge battle from Aegon's conquest called
the field of fire when the Targaryen
used three dragons to roast thousands of
men on the battlefield
so these Lannister chumps will be
barbecued but what about Jaime we see
him charging across the burning field
who's he attacking surely not Dany and a
dragon's right or he'd be eaten alive
then again
Jaime in the books believes he cannot
die while Cersei lives that the twins
will die together as they were born
together there are some amazing theories
here which we'll cover in a cersei video
soon but yeah this battle looks pretty
crazy we see grey worm have a moment
with Masson die before a battle between
Danny's unsullied and the Lannisters
it's possible this castle they're
attacking is Casterly Rock a huge
Lannister fortress and it's interesting
that these unsullied seem to be opening
this gate from inside how'd they get in
this might be part of a plan worked out
by Tyrion cuz Tyrion grew up in Casterly
Rock this was his home and when Tyrion
was 16 his father Tywin put him in
charge of all the drains and systems
there maybe Tyrion knows some back
entrances into the rock so grey worm can
get in or sneaky-like and open the gates
from within
kind of like how Danny took marine so
yeah with Tyrians tricks on their side
Danny might just capture the Lannisters
strongest castle Cersei will not be
pleased by the way we see Jaime walking
around some unfamiliar castle and
there's a dead guy on the ground did
Jamie just lead some attack on who this
could maybe be Highgarden the seat of
the Tyrells who along with the sand
snakes are Danny's allies against Cersei
again it's ominous that these guys
aren't in the trailer a further north we
see our riding probably to Winterfell to
finally reunite with a long-lost family
Sansa and Jon Snow who haven't seen eyre
since season one John and aya especially
were really close early on so it'll be a
hugely emotional moment for the Starks
to get back together after all that
they've been through Littlefinger
meanwhile still seems to be trying to
divide them he says some nonsense about
fighting every battle everywhere always
in your mind which means something
Littlefinger seems to think himself very
clever that his whole plan seems to
hinge on Sansa betraying her family for
him which probably will not happen given
that Sansa in the trailer says when the
snows fall and the wide winds blow the
lone wolf dies but the pack survives
this is what Ned tells aya way back in
book 1 and it's about stark solidarity
sticking together to survive so Sansa
won't listen to Littlefinger in fact
promo shots have shown aya
wearing the Valyrian steel dagger that
Littlefinger used to betray Ned so some
fans speculate that ire and Sansa will
kill Littlefinger with his own blade to
avenge the death and destruction he
brought on their family another stark
bran passes through the wall with Meera
and it looks like he too arrives at
Winterfell here he is in the godswood
with some new wheels so much has changed
since he was lost here it's not clear
who the guy standing next to him is
maybe Davos or maester wolkan or like a
obi-wan Force ghost of Bloodraven hard
to say
either way bran psychic powers will be a
really big deal this season for one
thing brand now knows that Jon Snow's
mother is Lyanna stark so that'll be a
big truth on though the next logical
question will be
whose John's dad also at Winterfell our
Brienne and Podrick name a more iconic
chewer
I'll wait we see John venture North with
an all-star team of warriors including
tormund and the hound and beric
Dondarrion with his flaming sword there
are million reasons why this team is the
coolest thing ever some of the greatest
fighters alive from opposite sides
brought together Sandor and Barrack
fought before in facts and or killed
Barrack then he was resurrected
berrak was resurrected John was
resurrected everyone thought the Hound
was dead before he was metaphorically
reborn this is almost a team of The
Walking Dead fighting the walking dead
because they battled the zombies the
whites controlled by the white walkers
fans have pointed out that the same
looks a bit like the story of the last
hero from the books who said to have
fought the walkers thousands of years
ago apparently the heroes set out into
the dead lands with a sword a horse a
dog and twelve companions and there are
twelve companions in this shot John has
his sword long claw and his dog could be
ghosts or maybe the Hound in the story
the last hero's friends were killed
along with his horse and his dog he even
lost his sword maybe that's what's
happening in these shots of John he's
still got a horse and a sword but he's
alone have tormund Sandor and Derek
being killed in the story of the last
hero the hero is almost caught by the
walkers but is saved by the children of
the forest those mysterious forest
hippies who hung out with Bloodraven the
analogue here might be for John to be
saved by brands magic we see Ravens
flying over the army of the Dead one
with white eyes the birds are being
magically controlled by bran he might
use them to attack the walkers maybe to
save John though he might be too laced
to help John's companions bran walking a
bird is also a fulfillment of what
Bloodraven tells him in dance that bran
will never walk again that he will fly
it's tragic that bran was robbed of his
ability to walk he wanted to be a knight
as a child but magic gives him the power
to do something even higher a
complication though it might be the
action between bran and the night king
we still don't really know the meaning
of this mark that the king left on brand
but it seems to suggest some connection
between the two like some Harry Potter
Voldemort [ __ ] we might see some intense
psychic battles between bran and the
night king this season so there's huge
stuff happening in the north and in the
south amidst Ice and Fire but there's
one more thing that might just happen
that could be the greatest moment of all
we get a shot of what looks like the
Hound somewhere in the south maybe in
King's Landing which just happens to be
where the mountain is Sandor and gregor
clegane
brothers remember years ago gregor gave
sandal the burns the disfigured his face
and there's hated each other ever since
they've both changed dramatically over
the series Sandor was symbolically
reborn while Gregor was quite literally
reanimated the fans have speculated for
years that these brothers will clash in
the greatest Westerosi grudge match
imaginable a combat commonly called
cleganebowl
it's kind of Darmon probably what
happened but man it really would be
quite cool anyway this season is going
to be crazy with heaps of long-awaited
moments
Dany at Dragonstone you're on on the
attack dragons in battle the fall of the
rock stock family reunion brand finally
flies and winter arrives at last thanks
for watching like and subscribe for more
videos and thanks to the patrons for
making this possible including Jalal
gasoline's Lars Larsen boots Davies
watcher of the shift' Sofia Fernandez
debe noodle and does Cheers
you